fine fine since everyone won't stop
asking I've decided to give you all what
you want and do a horror history episode
on why born Lovat from Coraline and the
truth is YB was only created for the
movie he's not in the book at all so he
technically has no history so remember
to subscribe to see Z's world for new
Horrors every week wring that death pill
now obviously I don't have to go off of
the movie and the movie alone for this
episode but if you want to hear what
goes on with YB while he's off screen
then stick around to the end of this
video part of what makes the world of
Coraline special is that the artistic
choices made reflect the themes of the
story the book tells the tale of a girl
who finds this fake world and is
intrigued by the small differences that
it has to her world I like to think of
the film as a whole as its own worlds to
be treated differently than the book and
the most noticeable difference the
snowglobe of the film if you will is the
inclusion of Y be welcome to horror
history my name is why was I born and in
today's lesson we'll be covering the
character who probably owns the most
Jack Skellington merch wyborn Lovat of
course there is a much more practical
reason for why B's inclusion as
explained by the director Henry Selick
in an interview with cinema black when I
decided to add the character of Y B I
realized that Coraline needed somebody
in her real world to talk to another kid
seems like the most simple way gap but
the character that ended up on screen
was much more than a glorified
exposition prompter so in order to
understand why B's importance to the
lore and history of this dark twisted
world let's take it back to the
beginning of his story
why be looks to be about core lines age
and lives with his grandma in a property
not far from the Pink Palace Apartments
where Coraline wins it is not known what
happened to his parents but we do know
the fate of his great end she once lived
with why Bea's grandmother in the pink
palace before it was converted into
separate apartments as discussed in the
horror history episode on the other
mother living at the Pink Palace made
her a target from the beldam in the
movie the beldam spies on her potential
victims through the eyes of this doll
which is placed in the real world for
the children to find why these great
aunt became attached to the doll and one
day she disappeared and became trapped
in the belphins world I think why Bea's
grandmother suspected some foul play
because she moved out of the palace when
she was old enough and when it became
hers she renovated it into apartments
and didn't allow families with children
to move there until the events of
Coraline we don't know why Coraline is
an exception to this rule but there is
one line to suggest that she simply had
to rent the place to the Joneses because
of anti age discrimination locks
surprised she let you move in my grandma
she owns the Pink Palace rented people
with kids what do you mean I'm not
supposed to talk about it on a sidenote
why Bea's grandma is referred to as
grandma throughout most of the movie and
why Bea's grandmother in the credits at
one point Coraline refers to her as Ms
Levent
the woman doesn't correct Coraline so by
that logic it was her son that was why
Bea's father passing down the last name
Lovat all the way to him the fact that
she is ms Lovat rather than mrs. Lovat
also suggests that she gave birth to why
Bea's dad out of wedlock meaning that
why Bea's grandfather hasn't been part
of the picture for some time now it's
also possible that Coraline just didn't
know whether to call her misery after
the disappearance of her sister she
locked the doll away in a chest until it
was reclaimed by the beldam and turned
into a Coraline doll where it was then
put back in the chest 4yb define other
than exploring the area around his house
on his electric bicycle why he seems to
be passionate about photography he makes
friends with a wild cat which he
sometimes feeds in exchange for the dead
things that the cat brings him at nights
he first encounters Coraline after she
moves in when he hears a scream after
the cat had startled her he approaches
and mistakes her for a water witch and
rides in to take the stick that he
perceives to be her dowsing rod when
they meet we see that despite his
intimidating appearance he's actually
pretty shy oftentimes stuttering and
avoiding eye
contact his hunched-over posture does
not exert confidence which coupled with
the information that kids are never
usually moved into the Pink Palace we
can conclude that he doesn't have any
friends
other than the cat that is Coraline has
the same issue at the beginning of her
story she's constantly bored and none of
the adults around her have time to play
with her despite this Coraline and YB
don't really get along when they first
means YB does tell her about the
location of the well though before his
grandmother calls him in ringing a bell
for him as she does so YB seems
embarrassed by his grandmother strict
control over his whereabouts I believe
this may be because after all of these
years she's still scarred by losing her
sister and fears the same could happen
to her grandson if he gets too close to
the Pink Palace as a result YB has never
been inside of the building grandma kill
me so he goes home and finds the doll
which he recognizes to be identical to
Coraline and leaves it on her porch with
a note the next morning he's snooping
around and spies on her using some kind
of periscope helmet when she catches him
he claims to be hunting banana slugs
director Henry Selick may have gone with
banana slugs as the creature of choice
to set up what happens to the other YB
later in the story
Coraline claims to be annoyed by YV
because of his loud mouth causing the
other mother to create a mute version of
him in the other world banana slugs have
a defense mechanism where the mucus that
they release contains chemicals that are
capable of numbing the tongue of their
predators
despite Coraline claiming not to like YB
she does still seem to enjoy taking the
photos of him in various poses with the
banana slug outside of one other
encounter with Coraline were why he
claims that mr. bubinski is jumping
mouse circuses Ally the two would not
encounter each other until the next day
but Coraline does meet his doppelganger
the other YB
as we established when I covered the
history of the other mother the button
I'd doppelganger forms of each character
found in the other world aren't really
connected to their real-world
counterparts however the duplicate
versions can still teach us about the
nature of the originals because the
other mothers intention was to create
more enticing forms of the people in
core lines life
as with the other father and the other
YB seems to have a mind of his own and
only acts the way he does out of fear
for the bells in addition to being
friendly and incapable of speech he's
also less shy stands up straight and
wears more conventional clothes he seems
to be the more ideal version of YB to be
friends with Coraline but like the
endless amounts of delicious food and
the freedom offered by the beldon's
world's other YB ends up being another
example of things being better off as
they were initially Coraline maybe
doesn't realize how lonely she is and
maybe having a friend who doesn't talk
isn't doing her any favors in that
regard one of the first things that
Coraline asks him is if the treatment
used to make him silent caused him any
pain and he immediately changes the
subject probably knowing that he's under
constant scrutiny by the other mother
the to go to see the jumping mouse
circuits the very same jumping mouse
circus that the real YB called the S on
after seeing Coraline off to bed before
she exits from the other world that
nights the other YB shows that he really
does have good intentions by warning the
cats about the true nature of the
Otherworld
Coraline returns to her world and while
YB is nowhere to be seen the next day
when mr. and mrs. Jones take their
daughter into town to buy a uniform
there aren't other kids in that scene
which tells us two things first
Coraline shows no interest in meeting
them despite her loneliness because of
their erratic behavior which could be a
clue that the often awkward and reserved
YB could actually be a more compatible
friendship for her she may have gotten
the wrong idea about him from their
initial meeting and second there are
other kids nearby so the fact that we
never see YB play with or talk about any
other kids could mean that he has no
friends and maybe I'm assuming too much
by saying this but it's easy to imagine
him being bullied for his outlandish
fashion choices and unconventional
hobbies the other YB on the other hand
pun intended is copied from the original
YB but changed in ways that the beldam
thought to be improvements both versions
seem to like Coraline and want to help
her in the case of the other y being the
beldum may have made him friendly and
likeable because her goal was to try to
make Coraline want to stay she probably
didn't realize that the other Y these
good intentions would be used against
her I could see her thinking that making
him mute would stop him from helping
Coraline in any way
but that ends up not being the case the
other YB is forced to accompany her to
the theater where he has a very weird
reaction to seeing the nearly naked miss
forcible he keeps up the cheery attitude
until he's no longer needed as Coraline
goes inside the other mother gives him a
harsh reminder that he needs to keep on
a smile the whole time despite the fact
that he's clearly unhappy while Coraline
is locked away in the mirror realm the
other mother punishes the other YB for
his insubordination she uses her
seamstress abilities to tie his mouth
into a permanent smile ensuring that
he'll never give any negative energy
towards Coraline it's basically like
when you go to a fast-food restaurant
and the person at the counter is smiling
because they don't want to get fired but
deep down they're probably like someone
get me out of here at this point I think
that other YB has been pushed to a
breaking point he's been brought into
this world by the other mother and
forced to do her bidding he may not have
had any hope for himself but thought
that he could at least do the brave
thing and make sure that Coraline
doesn't share the same fate ironically
he wears a chicken mask to cover up his
forced smile when he reaches into the
mirror to rescue her and she removed the
cover-up to find that the other YB was
no chicken at all he manages to sneak
her back to the gateway between the two
worlds but when she tries to invite him
to come along his hand to roads into the
stuffing used to make the doll that was
used to spy on each target I think this
was his way of telling her that he has
no way to survive out there in the real
world he was just a tool created by the
beldam no different than the doll that
Coraline would discard in the fire we
never see the other YB again after that
but we can assume that he no longer
being useful to the other mother was
discarded as well the other mother hangs
his clothes on the flagpole atop her
world as a warning to all of her other
creations about what will happen if they
disobey her meanwhile the original YB is
still fine and well but he gets himself
into a different kind of trouble his
grandmother is upset with him for
stealing the doll that once belonged to
her sister YB tries to go back to core
lines flat to ask for it explaining that
it wasn't his to give and this causes
Coraline to realize that Miss Lovat
sister and the ghost girl she had
encountered are one in the same she
brings YB inside his first time setting
foot in the Pink Palace and tries to
explain everything that she knew about
the other world which of course sounds
crazy crazy
and she gets upset and chases him out
but when he returned home he would find
something that changed his views on
Coraline story his grandmother showed
him a picture from her childhood the
photograph shows him his Lovat and her
sister who is holding the doll which YB
recognizes from Coraline story he rushes
out to try to find her and apologize for
not believing her and finds her headed
back to the old well before he gets the
chance to say anything she is attacked
by the rogue hand of the Belvin using
the same tongs that he uses to catch the
banana slugs he rides in and saves her
but nearly throws himself into the well
in doing so Coraline saves him from
falling in but exposes herself to an
attack that is when why he puts an end
to it by crushing the hand with a rock
rescuing Coraline and finally avenging
the great aunt that he never met in
doing so together they throw the hand
down the well and as far as we know the
beldam is never heard from again
why he apologizes for not believing
Coraline sooner but she isn't upset and
asked him to bring his grandma by the
house so that they can explain
everything together I took this ending
is not only the ending to the Belgium's
reign with the cat being seen taking
advantage of the freedom to now travel
between worlds as he pleases but also
the ending of Miz lo bats paranoia about
the curse of the Pink Palace and the
children who inhabitants she would
finally be able to rest easy knowing
that her sisters ghost was not in agony
and finally it marks the ending of
loneliness for both Coraline and YB who
now each had a new friend their age
click the playlist on the left for my
full list of horror history episodes
including those on the other characters
of Coraline and remember to subscribe to
see ZZZ world for new Horrors every week
ring the death beldam for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]